danger ha construido una perrera
rectangular de 21 pies de largo vamos a
marcar la información importante tenemos
21 pies de largo y tiene un perímetro de
78 pies el perímetro total será 78 pies
cuánto mide el ancho de la perrera para
que nosotros podamos imaginar esta
perrera vamos a dibujar la mejor
tendremos el ancho de la perrera y aún
no lo conocemos lo llamaremos ancho
ok y como es un rectángulo tendrá dos
largos dos lados largos
que me quedaron muy bonitos
tenemos los dos lados largos que cada
uno medirá 21 pies estamos de acuerdo y
finalmente para cerrar nuestro
rectángulo volverá a tener esta medida
que es el ancho
para que nosotros podamos tener el
perímetro total de un rectángulo pues un
perímetro es la suma de este ancho más
este lado más este ancho más este lado
es toda esta distancia que rodea el
rectángulo así es que vamos a hacer algo
vamos a escribir qué ancho
este más ancho
será este de aquí abajo más 21 que es
uno de los lados más 21 que es el otro
lado
será igual a 68 igual a 78 perdón 78 que
son los 78 pies totales del perímetro
ancho más ancho más 21 más 21 será igual
a 78 podemos reescribir esto
simplificando un poco y diremos que
ancho
más ancho
más
la suma de 21 más 21 que es igual a 42
será igual a 78 vamos bien
simplemente sumamos estos dos números
que ya tenemos que nos representan los
dos lados largos entonces podemos pensar
que tenemos aquí un algo
digamos que algo un número que nos dará
aquí
este número más 42 será igual a 78
estamos de acuerdo
este número más 42 será igual a 78 que
es el total del perímetro pero nosotros
vamos a ver cuál será este algo entonces
también podemos verlo como que 78 menos
42 será igual a este número que
tendremos a ese algo entonces pongamos
que ancho más ancho
será igual a 78
- 42
y lo podemos hecho de una vez escribir
tendremos que ancho más ancho
será igual a vamos a hacer la operación
78 menos 42 82 67 menos 43 ancho más
ancho será igual a 36 y de hecho lo
podemos comprobar saben porque si
tenemos que ancho más ancho
es igual a 36 escribamos lo aquí
36 42 de hecho el 78 estamos de acuerdo
vamos a colocar que esto también es 36
ahora tenemos que ancho más ancho es
igual a 36 tenemos un número que no
conocemos aún pero ese número sumado a
sí mismo nos está dando 36 cómo puedo
saber cuál es ese número pues muy
sencillo porque si pensamos respecto a
nuestras tablas de multiplicar sabemos
que si tenemos un número que se suma a
sí mismo pues esto realmente nos
representa dos veces ese número o dos
por ese número
ok 2 por ese número me dará igual a 36
y puedo pensar de alguna otra manera
cómo sacar este número haremos un poco
de álgebra en este momento sé que en
todo no aprendemos el álgebra pero en
vídeos más adelante lo veremos lo que
aquí quiero que ustedes vean es que el
número
y estamos buscando que en este caso es
ancho
va a ser igual a 36
dividido entre dos porque si aquí lo
tengo dos veces ancho
36 pues una sola vez ancho será hice 36
entre 2
y 36 entre 2 lo puedo pensar de dos
maneras que número sumado a sí mismo me
da 36 pues será
18 vamos a ponerlo con un color nuevo
1818 es igual a 36 de la misma manera
que 18 por 2 es igual a 36 ojo 36 entre
2 me dará 18 como les decía más adelante
ustedes van a tener vídeos de álgebra en
este momento pudimos sacar el perímetro
simplemente con las nociones básicas
ideológicas que conocemos ok
así es que nuestra respuesta correcta
será que el ancho de este rectángulo
será igual a 18 18 aquí 18 pies aquí y
18 pies aquí
si hacemos la suma total nos dará igual
a 78 que es el perímetro de nuestro
rectángulo